das hier ist jetzt sein zimmer 8 1358
dass er halt für diese 300 euro gekriegt
hat das müsste die 6248 sein
also er hat eigentlich nicht diese 8000
irgendwas als zimmernummer sondern eine
ganz andere
das heißt nur für die doku sind die
eigentlich in diesem zimmer
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bayern wie ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch jetzt gut entschuldigt bitte noch
mal diesen kahlen hintergrund ich hab's
immer noch nicht geschafft hier
irgendwas anzubringen das kommt aber auf
jeden fall noch aber ist halt auch gar
nicht wichtig also es geht ja nicht um
einen schönen hintergrund sondern oder
ein spannendes video ja heute für die
meisten von euch werden sich sicherlich
an das video von mir erinnern wo ich um
bestellungen dame gemacht habe zu diesem
beitrag der damals über mich auf zdf
lief also im fernsehen vielleicht noch
mal kurz zusammengefasst da ging es
eigentlich so schon ziemlich krass darum
wie man als youtuber seinen zuschauern
irgendwas vorgaukelt und das alles
eigentlich nur quatsch ist und und
aufwendiger blödsinn und so also es wird
schon sehr sehr schlecht dargestellt ich
bin echt und du bist echt und wir sind
echt und wir sind eine gut so also wir
sind eine familie irgendwie das ist
natürlich und die heutige video idee
hatte ich ganz spontan am morgen beim
duschen ja früher hatte ich auch immer
wieder den duschen in letzter zeit nicht
mehr so aber jetzt mal wieder
und das ist wirklich glaube ich ganz gut
weil ich möchte heute den spiels nämlich
einfach mal umdrehen und wir schauen mal
was im fernsehen vielleicht so ein
bisschen feld ist ich habe zum beispiel
letzte woche eine doku geguckt also
einen dokumentationsfilm mit wirklich
eine krasse sache aufgefallen vor allem
ich studiere kommunikationsmanagement
das hat auch ziemlich viel somit währung
zu tun und wir reden da auch viele was
fernsehen und mir diesen ganzen
hintergrund infos die man dadurch kriegt
also das fand ich schon kann aber gut
also seid wirklich gespannt umschreibt
gerne eure meinung zu den filmen die
kommentare es geht heute um drei fälle
und ich würde sagen gefangen halten euch
das erste video das ich mir ausgesucht
habe ist dieses hier selbst versucht 14
tage und dusche ist ein beitrag von
galileo und ich muss sagen ich habe
früher sehr gerne galileo geguckt weil
ich mich dadurch halt so ein bisschen
weiter gebildet habe man viele sachen
lernt klar aber jetzt in letzter zeit
wenn ich da mal so ein paar weitere
gesehen denke ich mir schon so also
früher war das irgendwie echt besser
natürlich ist dieser beitrag ist auch
schon über ein jahr alt
aber ich weiß nicht wer kommt für mich
wirklich sehr gestellt rüber und einfach
so hin geklatscht und an sich ist
galileo das wissensmagazin für
vielleicht auch eher jüngere und da
sollte man so was ja ganz klar vermeiden
weil ich auch direkt sagen muss das ist
jetzt kein extremfall ist
wir kommen gleich mein vater ist
wirklich viel viel heftiger zeigen
einfach mal nur folgende szene das
reicht dann eigentlich auch schon ich
weiß auch gar nicht wie viel ich
überhaupt zeigen kann an
schulterblättern super nervig und am
liebsten die ganze zeit sind da sitzen
wir sind ja noch andere gäste durch das
nicht waschen ist johannes haut
stellenweise ausgetrocknet und hat
winzige risse bekommen also jetzt
überlegt euch mal dass in 14 tagen
insgesamt sind jetzt gerade bei tag 9
und seine haut reißt so jetzt ist der
typ zum arzt gegangen und die ärztin
stellt jetzt hier eine diagnose fest
nach neun tagen also bei johannes konnte
man stark die geruchsbildung feststellen
ich muss mal ganz kurz gucken ob es
überhaupt diese esther wie es männer
gibt oder ob das wirklich eine herzens
ist ich will niemandem etwas
unterstellen klar vielleicht vielleicht
ist das wirklich so
aber das halte ich für sehr
unrealistisch weil allein schon wenn ich
jetzt hier die die volle bezeichnung
angebe mit dem medizinischen begriff
dermatologin müsste ja zu 100 prozent
die frau kommen korrigiert mich gerne
wenn ich falsch liege aber eigentlich
ist ja jeder arztpraxis mittlerweile
erreicht man über google ist ja auch
ganz wichtig und ich würde hier dringend
empfehlen das experiment abzubrechen
also die empfiehlt jetzt das experiment
abzubrechen und das war so der
ausschlaggebende punkt für mich gedacht
hat ist es jetzt euer ernst ich habe
mich dann auch mal weiter informiert und
in amerika gibt so typen die haben ein
ganzes jahr nicht geduscht von da ist
nichts passiert und ich war auch schon
mal sieben tage im krankenhaus konnte
nicht duschen
das ist absolut kein problem und da
reißt keine haut oder so also bei mir
zumindest nicht jetzt haltet euch fest
jetzt kommt nämlich noch ein paar
schauspielerischen künste vom reporter
ich habe keine ahnung was ich machen
soll der profi sagt an der stelle
aufhören abbrechen oder das war halt
einfach noch bis die bakterien wirken
kann ja keine ahnung gut also den fall
wollte ich sehr gerne mit reinnehmen
kommt für mich halt absolut gestellt und
viel gröber ich meine experiment machen
14 tage und dusche dass wir auf so ein
video was theoretisch ich mal machen
könnte also wenn es zur unterhaltung
dient aber dann auch noch so
medizinisches fachwissen mit
reinzubringen von anhaltender ärztin die
man so gar nicht wirklich finden kann
würde ich dann schon krass für galileo
wenn ihr verstehen was meine könnte
sagen eure meinung in die kommentare
schreiben
wir machen weiter auch dem nächsten fall
freue ich mich ganz besonders dann muss
ich auch erstmal was zu sagen und zwar
haben wir hier eine doku vom wdr der wdr
zu den öffentlich rechtlichen in
deutschland also wie ard zdf mdr und so
weiter also sender für die wir alle geld
zahlten diese gez gebühr wäre vielleicht
schon mal gesagt und die aufgabe von
diesem sendern ist es halt ja
informationen zu vermitteln also
bildungsauftrag das ist so das stichwort
sag ich mal
und hier haben wir jetzt eine doku vom
wdr und da dachte ich auch so ach du
scheiße das ist ja immer also das ist
wirklich traurig dass man dann bei
seinem sender halt so was auffliegen
lassen kann also dieser typ ia der macht
eine kreuzfahrt mit billig kreuzfahrt
hat 333 euro dafür bezahlen dass ein
zimmer ich war die letzten tage echt
ziemlich krank und hab mir das einfach
mal angeschaut und bin dann auf diese
stelle hier gestoßen
5 das hier ist jetzt dein zimmer auf
1358 dass er halt für diese 300 euro
gekriegt hat 333 euro dafür gibt bitte
also wir sehen heute ein ganz kleines
zimmer seinen koffer liegt schon dort
auf dem bett und da ist im team ein
großer fehler passiert und so habe ich
denn hier gefunden moment ein vorteil
aber ansonsten auch gepäck ist da hat
alles wunderbar zack jetzt halten wir
hier mal an genau bei 66 minuten 30 habe
es auch in den kommentaren hier sogar
gelesen und ihr könnt jetzt hier
wahrscheinlich die nummer sehen
ich bin das euch mal ein und suchen ein
bisschen rand drehe das ganze
das müsste die 6248 sein
also er hat eigentlich nicht diese 8000
irgendwas als zimmernummer sondern eine
ganz andere
das heißt nur für die doku sind die
eigentlich in diesem zimmer ich habe mir
das schiff mal ausgesucht das ist die
costa luminosa und da werden alle zimmer
vorgestellt auch das 6248 in der
kategorie premium mit balkon
also ich finde das schon wirklich witzig
und das ist natürlich ganz weit entfernt
von diesen 333 euro
und dann stelle ich mir halt diese frage
oder das ist eigentlich eine tatsache
dass es sich hierbei dann gar nicht mehr
um so ein bildungs beitrag handelt für
halt alle leute die sich dafür
interessieren sondern ein geschenk für
werbung wie gesagt ich will niemanden
was unterstellen
aber das ist dann schon hart wenn du das
wdr für billig kreuzfahrten wir mehr
kann ich dazu nicht sagen vielleicht ist
es ja auch nicht so vielleicht gehört
dieser koffer hier auch nur irgendwie
vom produktionsteam warum der dann bei
kunden kabine hat das ist glaube ich
etwas besseres gibt keine ahnung aber
gut
ich möchte das geld was dieser
öffentlich rechtlichen sendern zur
verfügung haben von uns ist sicherlich
auch mal locker eine premium kabine
dritten also das war für mich jetzt der
krasseste fall ein halber noch den habe
ich auch irgendwie leisten schon mal
gesehen hat dass wir nicht auch finde
ich auch schon echt komisch und diesmal
geht es auch um den prosieben sendet ab
ist ja auch so nachrichten sind nach
boulevard nennt sich das glaube ich also
die machen halt einfach unterhaltsame
nachrichten würde man so aber es ist
meiner meinung nach auf jeden fall ein
tv-format das jetzt nicht so scripted
reality macht wie zum beispiel auf
streife blaue import oder was weiß ich
hilf mir hilft mir das überhaupt war das
nicht obwohl wer kennt das nicht auf
jeden fall habe ich immer gedacht dass
das was die dort zeigen auch wirklich
personen sind die sich in dieser lage
befinden sagen wir es mal so und dann
habe ich mir irgendwann hier mal knast
wegen illegalen waffen problem kids in
den karpaten angeguckt
das ist emmi die 21 jährige hamburgerin
saß wegen illegalem waffenbesitz ist
bereits in spanien im gefängnis auch in
deutschland kommt sie immer wieder mit
dem gesetz in konflikt ja also und da
dachte ich warte mal die kennt ihr dürft
und dann habe ich mal nachgeguckt da ist
mir aufgefallen die hat man bei 53 67
mitgespielt das habe ich nämlich so wo
ich 15 war echt gerne geguckt
ist ja auch okay oder also es handle
sich um eine schauspielerin
erster auftritt folge 569 folge 569
april 2015
und dieser beitrag von tag wurde 200
jahre später raus gebracht
das heißt es ganz klar das was da gesagt
wird stimmt so nicht also dass es sich
halt um problemkiez handelt das thema
europa und denen da oben in den thermen
brachten
warum nicht am anfang dachte ich es wäre
alles nun wirklich schlechter witz dass
wir jetzt ja schlafen seiner gut
will ich es auch gar nichts sagen ich
mein mann ist ja offensichtlich dass das
heck ist das sieht man ja wenn ich um
ehrlich zu sein ein bisschen schade ich
meine das sind ja jetzt so beweise dafür
meiner meinung nach wirklich auf eure
kommentare gespannt dass man im
fernsehen auf kleinsten alles mehr
glauben solche und auch nicht wenn es
von den öffentlich-rechtlichen sender
stammt ja deswegen zusammengefasst zum
schluss bevor man youtuber durch den
kakao zieht auch an die eigene nase
fassen das was man mir ich hoffe dass
wieder hat euch gefallen dass er sehr
gerne daumen nach oben da und wir sehen
uns morgen gibt es wieder ein
unterhaltsames video kathrein